okay hi there
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others let me make a couple
of logistical comments
so people have been asking all kinds of
questions which i find really fun
um hopefully people have been finding
the answers interesting
uh we've decided to kind of separate uh
several different streams of this
so i'll be doing the science and
technology q a
weekly um i also for
uh other people with other interests
we're going to do
a business and innovation q a
more for grown-ups so to speak
and that will be every other week and
then the intervening weeks
we'll be doing a history of science and
technology q a
and then i will be doing monthly uh
probably a physics project q a which
will be
suitable for much more technical
questions about physics
um and we have one of those coming up in
about a week
so that's um for this uh for
this live stream i'm really hope to
concentrate on
all kinds of science and technology and
explaining things
and so on um probably not so much
on the um i'm happy to talk about some
life and times kinds of things
but uh not so much on the kind of more
business-like
uh uh end of things
all right so
let's see we have a few questions saved
up here uh there's one that that sort of
violates my principle about not talking
about details but from david uh have i
discussed
the physics project with any string
theorists oh yes
lots of string theorists um and
uh in fact we we have right now
our uh winter school
for our physics project uh so we we
limited that to 20 people
all physicists um at various stages of
uh
of education and so on and a number of
those people actually string theorists
but
but i've also uh talked to
a good fraction of the world's kind of
leading string theory
operatives about our project and i think
everybody kind of agrees that
that um uh you know we need to figure
out the kind of mathematical physics
links between
between our project and string theory
maybe i can um
uh for people's benefit i'm not seeing
um
uh any questions here so
i'll i'll um i could talk about what
string theory is
and um i could talk about um
let's see um
uh okay um
well we got a bunch of different
questions here i'm i'm a little bit
confused by what i'm seeing
um and uh
um
all right let's see
um
well all right shall we um
um it's a question here about clouds
which i'm pretty sure i answered
a couple of weeks ago um
the okay well let's talk about some
um okay here's a question from mitchell
uh asking about the possibility of
building an unmanned spacecraft
to hitch a ride on a comet to reach
and and perhaps launch the spacecraft
out of the solar system
all right that's a fun one let's um
let's talk about that uh
so first question is uh
what are comets so people
uh that was one of the achievements of
uh
newton isaac newton back in the 16 late
1600s
was figuring out that comets are sort of
just like planets
planets have orbits around the sun
they're really close to circles
um the uh the sun is at the center
planet orbits around what's happening is
the force of gravity
is uh is holding the planet in towards
the sun
and the force that the kind of
centrifugal force you know where like
when you twirl something around
uh with your hand there'll be a force
that's sort of pulling the thing
away from away from you and you're
you know if you have a string or
something the string is pulling the
thing back towards you
in the case of a planet what's happening
is that same kind of force that's
that's associated with the the planet
yeah here's a way to say it
if there were no forces acting on the
planet the planet if you
make it go in a certain direction it
will just keep going in a straight line
in order to get the planet the planet
doesn't do that because there's a force
associated
with gravity pulling the planet towards
the sun and so
but there's a effectively a force that
is trying to make the planet
uh go off and get get out of its orbit
because the planet really just wants to
keep going in a straight line
in order to keep it going in its orbit
you have to be continually
pulling it with the force of gravity
towards the sun
so the the most obvious way to have that
set
up is to have the force of gravity uh
pull you towards the sun at the center
and you're just going around in a
circular orbit
but the thing that was figured out by by
newton and friends
is that you can also have orbits where
um
you have the the the sun where the orbit
is actually in the lips
and where the sun is at one focus of an
ellipse so an ellipse
is an elongated circle you know if you
just take a circle
and let's say you're you're in a a you
know a
drawing program you just pull it out in
the
in the horizontal direction you squash
it down in the vertical direction
you'll get uh you start off with a
circle you you squash it in the
vertical direction you pull it in the
horizontal direction you will then get
an ellipse an ellipse is just a
transformed circle
but um one way that you can draw an
ellipse
well first to draw a circle you can just
put
uh something at the center and you have
a little a piece of string or
or or a compass and
you the piece of string is a fixed
length and you just keep going
around the thing at the center uh in a
circle
just uh always keeping it a fixed length
from
from that uh from that thing at the
center to door an ellipse
you can do the same kind of thing but
instead of having a single center you
have two
centers you have two folky foci of the
ellipse
and then you have a piece of string
which goes
from one uh foci of focus of the ellipse
to your pencil to the other focus of the
ellipse
so that means and then you move your
pencil around
um always keeping it so what what that's
doing is it's keeping
the the uh the the total distance from
those two foci
the same because the the you have the
same piece of string which has the same
total length
but the proportion of length going from
the first focus to the pencil
um is is is different as you move the
pencil around
and so if you if you do that you get
instead of getting
a circle that you get with a single
point at the center
by by having this thing with two points
you end up getting an ellipse
so then the thing that newton discovered
is that the the the sun
that you can have an orbit of of of
of of something around the sun where the
sun is at one focus of an ellipse
and then the the um the orbit can go
around
um like that and i'm just thinking how
do you
is there an elementary way to prove that
result
ah should be um
well never mind anyway that's um so a
comet
tends to be a thing in our solar system
that has a very eccentric orbit it has
an orbit
that isn't close to a circle that
instead is like an ellipse
where where uh the comet uh you know for
comet can be for a while very close to
the sun and then it can go very far out
uh from the sun maybe uh we the earth
orbits
by definition at roughly one
astronomical unit from the sun
but a comet might go 200 astronomical
units out or more
and then come back in towards the sun
so there are a variety of kind of
places where comets hang out or come
from in our solar system
um both um uh close in at the asteroid
belt
and further out at the oort cloud and
things that are far be
beyond uh the planets that we normally
identify
um and so you know comets are typically
these quite small objects they're often
made of uh they often have lots of ice
um on them and uh what happens the
reason comets are kind of really notable
in the when you see them in the sky is
that they have tails
um and uh so question is what is the
tail of a comet
tale of a comet is uh what
there's a there's a the sun
in addition to light coming from the sun
uh there's also
a solar wind a stream of particles
that come out from the sun that are uh
that stream outwards from the sun
and um that uh when when when there's a
comet
that's being heated by this as the comet
comes in towards the sun let's say the
comet is made of ice
the comet will be heated as it gets
towards the sun and that will cause the
ice
to uh actually in in at some at low
pressures
like in the vacuum of space ice we're
used to ice
when you heat it up just turning into
liquid water and then if you heat it up
more it will turn into steam
but in the low pressure of space uh ice
goes straight
from being in its solid phase to being
uh uh gaseous to being steam
and so what's what's happening is you
can get um
you get uh uh it's heated as
the comet comes in towards the sun it
gets heated up and some of the ice will
will sublimate will turn into uh into
steam effectively and then because of
the solar wind from the sun
the um uh that will tend to make the um
uh the the direction of the of the
particles of the water molecules and so
on
be away from the sun so when when you
look at a comet
you'll see the tail of the comet is
always pointing away from the sun um
and that uh so that's sort of a thing
that makes a comet noticeable
is is that it will have a have this kind
of tail behind it
um okay so the question then is
uh can you for example um
uh can you send a spacecraft to a comet
well a couple of spacecraft have been
sent to comets i think there was some
japanese spacecraft was the first one i
think a european one
um i think there may be i'm i'm losing
track of my deep space missions i'm not
sure if there's been an american one yet
i think there's one planned
um uh but anyway you can you can send
spacecraft to comets
um and uh there there's
attempt to actually retrieve material
from a comet
um the uh uh the thing that
um is a little weird comets are very
small
and so the gravity of a comet is very uh
you know
if you land on on the moon or on mars
there'll be a decent amount of gravity
on the moon it's about one-sixth the
gravity of earth
so you know if you see people astronauts
walking on the moon
you'll see that they take very big steps
because
with the force that they can exert with
their legs to walk
that um that same force will propel them
up much further six times further well
the the height is is uh square root of
that
no no the height will be that will be
proportional to that
um so
is that right well anyway the when the
gravity is smaller
the the the same force sort of uh
pushing one up as one walks will make
one take a much bigger sort of jumping
walk so on the moon the gravity is
one-sixth the gravity of the earth
on a comet uh because the comet is much
much smaller
the gravity will be much much much
smaller so even
if you have landed on the comet the
slightest mistake
and you you know the slightest kind of
uh thing that's pushing you down towards
the comet
you'll find that you just get you you
get pushed away from the comet and
you'll escape from the comet
like on the earth you have to be going
at 25 000 miles an hour
uh to escape the gravity of the earth on
a comet
you might have to go at you know just
you know one mile an hour
or less to escape the gravity of the
comet and to be sort of
floating off into space but so
a question i think the question was
asked is could one
sort of hop on a comet and then ride it
out to the outer solar system i
would think that would work i don't know
why that wouldn't work
um the uh you know things get difficult
um if you're um
you know i think the the problem of of
sort of attaching yourself to a comet
and and not falling off i'm sure if you
you know you have to
sort of grab it with claws in some way
so that you don't fall off
um if if there's any other uh if if
anything is pushing you away from the
surface
um i think there's there's also plenty
of issues
um uh as you go far from the sun
that the way most spacecraft like in
earth orbit get their power
is essentially all spacecraft in earth
orbit get their power from solar power
from photovoltaic cells which take the
light from the sun and converts it into
electricity just like solar panels
on a house or a electrical
supply utility that's using solar power
when you go
to the outer solar system the um uh
the power the the uh the the
the intensity of the sun has fallen off
to the point where
the sun is just this tiny dot in the sky
and there's very little intensity of
light
that falls on spacecraft and so it's uh
becomes
quite unrealistic to power the
spacecraft using solar power
when you get out far out uh from the sun
and so the most common uh way of
powering spacecraft that go out
that far is with um
with radioactivity not a nuclear reactor
where a nuclear in a nuclear reactor
you're
um uh you're you're using the fact that
well so
and what does it mean to to okay how
does radioactivity work at this level
the the i will explain that that um uh
your the way it works in a nuclear
battery
it's a common name for for these kinds
of things is different from the way a
nuclear power station
or a nuclear explosion works um
but in a in a nuclear battery the idea
is that you have a material
that is radioactive that basically means
that the nuclei of the atoms
are just self-destructing at some rate
and that happens um as a result of
uh the the it happens sort of randomly
for each atom
that's a result of kind of quantum
mechanics sort of basic ideas of physics
that there will be a certain for a
particular radioactive
uh uh element radioactive isotope the
isotope is just the configuration of the
nucleus of an atom
so for a particular uh radioactive
isotope there will be a certain
characteristic half-life which means
what's the uh what's the average amount
of time if you have uh
you know a thousand uh nuclei of that
type what's the average amount of time
before 500 of them will have decayed
so different nuclei that are unstable
have different
uh half-lives and when the nucleus
decays
the the you know you start over just
this nucleus and then it it
uh uh it decays and a piece of the
nucleus will
essentially fall off or the nucleus will
break in two
um and the pieces the the when that
happens
a fair amount of energy is released
essentially the the the pieces that come
out from the nucleus
will be uh that they they will turn
energy that used to be used in binding
the nucleus together
they'll turn that energy into energy of
motion of the of the things that come
out of the
decayed nucleus and so the idea of these
sort of nuclear batteries
uh tends to be to to take a radioactive
element and um uh let it decay
and then those decay products will be
going fast and
those decay products will heat something
up and then you use the heat that's
produced from those decay products
um to uh uh to to make electricity
um that you can use to power the
spacecraft
and there's been a certain um uh there's
a there's a whole sort of story
of being able to get the right kind of
um
nuclear isotopes to be able to put in
spacecraft and people have had a hard
time actually i think in the one of the
jupiter missions
um they they used some of the sort of
stockpile of
a us stockpile of reactive materials
um and there was uh sort of it's been
hard to get that stuff
because in the world at large um it's
it's uh people don't want to make
available these these
large amounts of regulated material
because you can use them to make bombs
and things like this
um and so that's it tends to be a thing
where there hasn't been so much of that
produced
um which makes it hard to to provide the
material for spacecraft
but anyway the the the sort of the
answer i i think it's
it's perfectly realistic to imagine sort
of attaching something to a comet and
having it to go off to the outer solar
system
how you keep it powered and how you keep
it transmitting
uh radio signals back to the earth is
you know a challenge of engineering
i mean i think the the most cool thing
to do would be
to hitch a ride on an interstellar comet
um there was so far only i think one has
been observed
with a strange name it was named uma
numer i think i think i'm saying that
correctly
this was something observed about two
years ago uh
there was a um a thing that looked like
kind of a comet asteroid you know
somebody in the solar system
and it was tracked with telescopes and
it was found that if you if you plotted
its orbit
it could not be orbiting around the sun
it was moving kind of uh
uh it was moving in such a way that it
just wasn't uh
wasn't part of something that was
orbiting around the sun so that means
that it was a
a piece of rock basically that was uh
coming from out of the solar system um
and just happened to be passing through
the solar system
and and people think that actually
there's a decent number of these
interstellar comets
or whatever that will pass through the
solar system but this particular one
uh you know a cool thing to be able to
do if one had one's act together quickly
enough and
and one would have to be uh i i think it
would be a challenge to get there
quickly enough
is go hitch a ride on this thing that is
uh tooling out of the solar system um
and um uh you know go
go use that to um uh um
uh to uh yeah to to
to to explore further you know i'm
realizing there's a bit of a problem
with what we're saying here
because in order to land on a comet you
have to kind of match the speed of the
comet
but by the time you're matching the
speed of the comet you will be going in
the same orbit as the comet
so in a sense it's not clear what the
advantage
of sort of hitching the ride is because
by the time you're by the time if you
want to land on a comet you better be
matching the speed of the comet if you
if you are crashing into the comet at
twenty thousand miles an hour
um well it's it's very challenging to
survive that um
but uh so by the time you're matching
the speed of the comet
um just by sort of the laws of mechanics
um you will have uh it if you have two
things in orbit
one of them is has a a large mass one of
them has a small mass
they will still have the same orbit um
so
so if you manage to match the speed of
the comet you will follow the same orbit
as the comet so i
i'm actually reversing myself here a bit
and saying that that
um i'm not sure there's a point in
hitching a ride so to speak i think
once you can match the speed of the
thing you're going to follow the same
orbit as
as the thing does um so yeah i should
have should have noticed that at the
beginning here
um
let's see um
yeah okay so so there's a question from
uh
matoy here uh commenting that they saw a
youtube recently where they discussed um
uh this
this uh uh
thing that was mentioned a few weeks ago
the radio telescope
had seen an unusual radio signal from
alpha centauri the nearest star other
than sun to us
um and uh that this was a very unusual
signal because it had a
frequency of around 982 megahertz
um and uh the the
what is this what can cause something
like this
you know people have been doing a lot of
searches
for okay so there's this kind of
you know big question are we the only
sort of intelligent things in the
universe
or are there other intelligences in the
universe who might be
doing things like what we're doing and
for example sending radio signals out
uh talking about all the wonderful
things they're doing or showing their
television programs
whatever else how would we how would we
detect
extraterrestrial intelligences and uh
you know how can we find signals of that
i think there's a
pretty fundamental problem one of the
big mysteries
often called the fermi paradox after a
physicist named enrico fermi
um the fermi paradox is uh how come
we haven't already met all of these
extraterrestrial intelligences after all
if we've managed to get to the stage
that we've managed to get to where we're
just starting to send spacecraft
a small distance out chances are
that in the history of the universe
we're not the first extra
you know the first intelligence how come
there aren't
intelligences that developed a million
years or a billion years earlier than us
that have been sending spacecraft all
over the the universe
how come we haven't met any of those
things how come
we still seem to be alone in the
universe with respect to
to intelligence i i personally think
that this is
likely a sort of misunderstanding of how
things work
and the nature of intelligence and so on
i think the issue is
that we might think you know we have to
ask what is the sort of abstract
definition of intelligence
and what we realized is that being able
to do computation being able to
take an input and apply
a sequence of rules to that input and
figure out what the output should be
that's essentially what our computers
are doing it's what our brains are doing
when we take certain stimuli you know i
read a question from
from here then i i sort of things happen
inside my brain and i start yakking and
saying things
um that's it's all sort of a
computational process
where in that case the sort of the rules
that govern the neurons in my brain and
so on
are are activating in some way and
producing an output
um this is you know these are all
computational processes
and we have to distinguish what's the
difference between the sort of
computational process
that's happening in our brains that's
causing us to say sensible or not
sensible things
versus the computational processes that
are happening i don't know when we see a
uh you know some a waterfall and we see
all of these complicated motions of
water
in the waterfall what's the difference
between the kinds of
computations that are happening in our
brains and in the water in the waterfall
well i used to think oh there's there's
a big difference between these things
there's something very special about
the things that are happening in our
brain that's a sign of some kind of
you know intelligence whereas the
waterfall is just doing what the
waterfall does
but what i realized as a result of lots
of science that i've done
is the the level of sort of assessing
these computations
there's really no difference in the
sophistication of the computations that
are going on in those two cases
they're really exactly equivalent it's a
thing i call the principle of
computational equivalence
but the issue is the waterfall doesn't
seem like it's
it's not human-like intelligence that
it's showing it's showing
a computation that's as sophisticated as
the computations going on in our brains
but it's not showing a computation that
we recognize as being
sort of purposeful in the same way that
we imagine the computations going on in
our brains are purposeful
so what we realize is in the universe
there's just tons of stuff
that is doing sophisticated computation
and that is in some abstract sense
intelligent there's extraterrestrial
intelligence all over the place
um that is abstractly intelligent
the issue is is it close enough in its
details to human intelligence
that we can kind of communicate with it
and kind of
understand and align our our sense of
purpose and our sense of how things work
with the way that that intelligence
works and that's the real question if we
look at the
the sort of the space of possible
intelligences we say here's human
intelligence
okay you know dolphin intelligence might
be somewhere off here
um and here's you know and somewhere
there's the abstract intelligence in the
waterfall
and it's somewhere off off in the
distance there so the question really is
how close is the in the sort of space to
possible intelligences
how close are other things that exist in
the universe
now it's a it's a sort of a bad sign
that if it even takes you know
we even consider the case of dolphins we
don't have great
sort of communication and understanding
of dolphin intelligence
and uh we imagine that it's somehow
inferior to human intelligence but maybe
that's just uh
you know maybe we're just a million
years too early maybe it's just that the
dolphins have a very elaborate
uh uh you know elaborate kind of
civilization we just don't recognize it
because it's a civilization that
involves you know dolphins communicating
by sending
you know vortices in the water by
flipping their fins or something
and we just have never never paid
attention to that we don't really know
um and we don't really understand how to
decode the vocalizations of
of uh of those kinds of animals and so
on so
we really we don't know it's the same as
the intelligence and the waterfall so to
speak
it's something that is that is that is
happening and it's computationally
sophisticated
but we don't we can't sort of align it
with the with the understanding that we
have
about how we think about things and so
really the the challenge of
extraterrestrial intelligence
is uh is there are their intelligences
close enough in intelligent space
to us that we can actually sort of align
with them
to understand their purposes and to
recognize them as being sort of
human-like intelligence so for the last
about 50 years
there have been attempts to kind of
detect radio signals that are kind of
potentially
uh things sent by sort of human-like
extraterrestrial intelligence
now the thing to realize is you know if
you're
uh if you're trying to imagine what
would be a form of communication by the
way even
thinking about the notion of
communication is kind of a very human
intelligence kind of notion but if you
imagine communication
you know a a common sort of science
fictiony type theory
tends to be oh you know there is a
a giant galactic social network going on
but it's communicating using some mode
of communication
that maybe we are just not yet plugged
into
so for example you know before a hundred
years ago
120 years ago uh you know nobody knew
about radio
so if there'd been an elaborate you know
if if the um
uh if the the the the extraterrestrials
at the
nearby stars were sending these you know
elaborate radio communications to us
it's like oh there's just a dumb planet
over there
they don't yet understand how to how
that there's a thing
radio well it could be the case that you
know maybe
somebody is modulating gravitational
waves and sending them to us and we're
just uh
oh that planet is too dumb to understand
you know this elaborate signal centered
gravitational waves or
neutrinos or in some kind of uh
deformation of space
time that we don't yet understand or or
some such other thing
uh and and so you know maybe there's a
maybe there's just a purely physical
uh means of communicating that is um
uh that we just don't know about and
that's the sort of key thing and and
once we know it all those human-like
extraterrestrial intelligences will sort
of come into view
but the thing that we have known about
radio communications on the earth
is it was the case 50
years ago that the way people
communicate
with radio is to use a particular
frequency of radio waves
you know when you tune a radio receiver
you're tuning it you know a radio
station might be you know
um i don't know 926 megahertz or
something might be a um
or whatever it is you know there might
be a radio station it will quote its
frequency
that's the main frequency of the radio
signal that is coming from that radio
station
and the way that the the uh the you know
the the music you're hearing from the
radio station or something
is encoded is well a couple of different
ways but nowadays the most common is
so-called frequency modulation where
basically
that frequency you think it's you know
900 megahertz for example
but actually it's 900 megahertz
900.01 megahertz for example and that's
the frequency right now and then it's
point
uh then it's 900 plus 0.02 megahertz and
so on
and those changes of frequency are
decoded by the radius receiver
to be changes of frequency of the sound
that you're hearing and so that would be
you know as the
as the frequency maybe is further away
from the the nominal
carrier frequency the nominal frequency
of that radio transmission
um you're hearing a a higher sound um
that uh that corresponds to and if it's
closer maybe you're hearing the lower
sound
the different ways to do that encoding
but basically
you have this this sort of main
frequency
you you're you know you've got one radio
station at 900 megahertz
another radio station at 902 megahertz
let's say
and you're you're tuning your radio
receiver to mostly receive radio signals
at that particular frequency and then
there's a small kind of modulation
around that frequency
that is the actual signal for the radio
station that's actually giving you the
the that's decoded into the sound you
hear and things like this
so 50 years ago that's how everything
worked actually 50 years ago
it was mostly so-called amplitude
modulation um
where where all you're doing is you you
have this fixed carrier you're
you're sending out this kind of you know
long
uh uh sort of beep from in
in radio and you you're just changing
the intensity of that beep slightly
and that's the way that you're encoding
the sound wave that you get to hear a
sound and then
amplitude modulation kind of gave way to
frequency modulation as a slightly
slightly better method um because uh
it's better because
because with amplitude modulation if um
uh if something changes in the um
uh if something changes in the way that
the signal is being transmitted
that causes more of the signal to be
attenuated the signal to just
get get smaller you that would be
translated into an actual change of the
sound you get out so to speak
whereas with frequency modulation it's
looking for a change of frequency which
is not something that happens
as naturally as a result of just sort of
going through a a cloud or
some other thing where the radio signal
might be transmitted through
so in any case you know standard thing
for us
humans using radio is you know somebody
gets the 900 megahertz slot somebody
else gets the 902 megahertz slot
somebody else gets the 908
megahertz slot and so on every different
radio station has a different slot
and you're sort of distinguishing these
radio signals by
the carrier frequencies that they use
and the way that when amplified radio
signals
was based on on tuning a so-called
resonant circuit
to be tuned to that particular frequency
and to
where the excitations in the circuit
would get bigger if they were
if they were excited just at that
frequency it's the same idea uh roughly
if you're on a swing
and you're swinging back and forth and
you you know i guess in america it's
called pumping the swing
um you're you're putting you're sticking
your legs out you're pulling your legs
in
and um if you you can get the swing to
go up higher
if you um uh if you you know stick your
legs out when you go forwards
back when you go back and so on and you
make
the the frequency with which you're
sticking your legs out pulling your legs
in
correspond to the natural frequency of
the swing and that will
that is an example of a kind of a
resonant process
where you're where you're sort of
increasing the amount you're swinging
by doing that and it's the same basic
idea is used in
in the the sort of basic amplifiers that
are used for for radio
depending on the and it depends you have
to set the amplifier up
to be tuned to a certain frequency
that's the sort of the
the traditional way to do this okay so
back 50 years ago
you sent a radio signal you use a
carrier frequency you pick a particular
frequency you're going to do that at
so when people started looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence
they said let's look for carrier
frequencies let's look for
so-called narrow band signals where
there's a particular frequency of radio
that's being transmitted and people
built all kinds of devices
to try and uh find is there any narrow
band signal you know
even even though there might be you know
we don't know whether they're going to
pick
this particular frequency or that
particular frequency but let's just look
for any
thing where there's a where there's
something where one's picked a
particular frequency
and then sent radio signals at that
frequency and i think
um people would try to guess or what
frequency would they use well
i think there was one popular one what
was it 1421 megahertz i think
is a so-called the waterhole frequency
which is a frequency where there are uh
there are uh when when radio signals
propagate through
through space if there's any uh
gas molecules for example in the way
there are particular
frequencies at which those gas molecules
can be
uh will absorb a lot more radio signals
they usually correspond to
excitations of the gas molecules the gas
molecules wiggling back and forth or
rotating or whatever at those particular
frequencies
a lot of radio uh signals will be
absorbed
because the radio energy goes into sort
of making the the water molecules or
whatever it is
do what they do rather than and so they
absorb the the radio signal as it goes
through
but there are particular frequencies at
which uh for whatever reason
there aren't uh they don't happen to be
uh excitation
frequencies for for various things like
water that are found as molecules in
in space and there's one particular one
which was kind of this hole where there
isn't
absorption in space and so that was sort
of a guess that people had i know 50
years ago or so now
for oh the extraterrestrials might use
that fact that you can get radio signals
through more easily at that frequency
let's look specifically at that
frequency but then the general idea was
let's look at a particular frequency
now that idea is in some ways quite
flawed because
if you look at radio transmissions on
the earth today
they are decreasingly specific to
particular frequencies
they're much more often uh
it's not the most efficient thing to do
you're putting a lot of energy into one
frequency it's more efficient to spread
the spectrum
to use spread spectrum communication as
successive different generations of cell
phone technology come in
they are more and more spread spectrum
5gs even more so
than 4g for example um and you you stop
having this kind of sharp
peak of a particular frequency and and
in fact even beyond that
the very idea of a broadcast way of
sending a radio signal where you say
i've got this radio antenna and it's
broadcasting in all directions this this
radio signal
that's kind of old news because if you
do that your radio signal
is like going in all directions and if
you are trying to send that signal to a
particular receiver
most of the energy that you're spending
is being spent sending the signal in all
the directions that are irrelevant
to sending the signal to that particular
receiver so for example in 5g
to cell phones there's a there's an
effort to have uh
uh a way of directing the signal so it's
essentially instead of just going in all
directions the antenna is set up
there's a so-called phased array which
sets it up so that
uh that it will tend to to direct the
the radio instead of going in all
directions to make the radio go in a
specific direction
you can do that with other kinds of
radio antennas like parabolic antennas
things like that um also have this
feature that they tend to direct
radio signals in a particular direction
um so
increasingly with communications on
earth we're trying to just say oh
there's a sender there's a receiver
let's pick who wants to receive it let's
just send to the receiver
sometimes like for radio navigation
beacons you
it's more convenient to just say oh
there's this broadcast thing it's going
in all directions anybody can sort of
passively listen to it
without registering i'm the receiver
send the signal in my direction
but anyway so so if we're even looking
for sort of the future of our
civilization
um i don't think the amount of sort of
radio energy
that is going to be just sort of going
off into space
sending it out as a as a giant radio
transmission that can be picked up
anywhere in the galaxy type thing
i think we'll we'll be doing that to a
decreasing extent
except insofar as we're specifically
sending signals for the purpose of
saying
hi we're here um and there's been a lot
of debate about whether we
as a species should be sending signals
into space saying
hi we're here um people you know it's
it's a
it's kind of a funny sort of question of
uh you know
if we're doing that it's like one thing
we're saying is oh you know hi we're
here
look at us we're we're so magnificent
we've discovered all these interesting
things
another view would be um you know
look at us and somebody will come and
say uh you know
if there's extraterrestrials that are
that are like you know humans in history
so to speak
let's just go take over that planet you
know more territory
better uh you know that that's a that's
a sort of projection from human behavior
in human history
that you might think that the
extraterrestrials will be like you know
oh we're going to go conquer the galaxy
type thing
and so by sending the signal saying hi
we're here
it's it's kind of an invitation to come
and come and uh
uh come and take over our planet which
would be
uh presumably a really bad thing um
so so there's a lot of debate on whether
signals should be sent and some signals
have been sent
um but the question is well maybe the
extraterrestrials are sending signals
maybe there are uh maybe their signals
that are just radio navigation beacons
from
from random extraterrestrials that we
could pick up etc etc etc
i think this is a somewhat flawed
concept because i think this kind of
distance and intelligence space is a
thing to think about and my guess
is that there's plenty of intelligence
in the in the galaxy in the universe
it just isn't really well aligned with
human intelligence and even in the
future of our
our civilization is probably not going
to be very aligned with the present of
our civilization
and and the kinds of uh you know our
ability to recognize oh yeah that really
is a purposeful activity
um you know across history has even been
quite poor even
over and across a few thousand years let
alone across
hundreds of thousands of years or
millions of years but anyway
uh you know people still look for the
duceties search for extraterrestrial
intelligence
and uh they look for for signals um
that might be signs of kind of
human-like intelligence
and narrowband signals is the is the
number one thing people look for
that's not clear people are really
looking for anything else nobody really
knows
any other good things to look for and um
so
every so often somebody will discover oh
whoops there's you know there's
there's some signal like this and one
was discovered i think in september of
last year
um near alpha centauri are coming
apparently from the direction of alpha
centauri
a a signal at a particular frequency and
it's like wow what can cause that
well you know one thing that can cause
that is a is a human-like
alien with a radio set you know with a
radio antenna
sending it but there are probably a lot
of things in physics that can also cause
that
the most common thing that will cause
narrow band um
emissions well okay so there are
um uh
there are okay there are spectral lines
there are things called masers
um the um uh base basically
uh specific kinds of atoms will tend to
have a characteristic frequency
at which they emit uh light or radio
signals
it's the same thing you know if you have
a um
uh something like a neon you know a neon
sign
that's that's the um the neon atoms
inside that tube
are being excited and they are emitting
light at a particular reddish frequency
um and that and for different kinds of
atoms they'll be different
characteristic frequencies
you can get intense emission in a mesa
which is the microwave analog of a laser
a laser is is amplifying light
and it amplifies light at a particular
frequency
that will depend on what medium and what
the what the material inside the laser
is
um similarly there's a microwave version
of that where you're amplifying radio
signals and that's another way you can
get sort of intense some
uh intense radio signal and there are
there are naturally occurring
masers um that exists in in uh
in the galaxy so to speak and that's a
that's a common source for a narrowband
signal
and then there are other things that
happen like for example
you could end up with a signal which
seemed to be narrowband
just because of the way you detected it
but actually it only lost it for a
microsecond
and it was just a random thing that you
couldn't tell was
was not typical of you know it's like if
you toss a coin
and you say you know you say uh like i'm
a real winner i got heads heads
heads heads ten times in a row um you
know it's like
is that you know getting heads ten times
in a row
is that just chance and uh if you look
over a longish
long enough period of time you'll get an
equal number of heads and tails
or is it a lucky coin or an unlucky coin
or whatever
or do you have some special uh you know
some special touch that's making it
always come up heads every time
um the uh you know that that's the thing
where you have to use statistics to try
to
figure out is what you're seeing
characteristic of the average or is it
something special
so i don't know more specifics of this
particular
um this particular observation i
probably should
should uh should learn more about that
let's see there's a question here uh
there's a quite different kind of
question about apis
um and uh
gosh i don't from taylor here not quite
sure i understand the details of this
but but let me let me just say a little
bit about apis
what apis are people who might have
heard of them or not heard of them so
when we use computers
it's we're humans we're communicating
with a computer somehow
we are like typing something into the
computer we're pressing on the computer
screen
it's an interface between us humans
and the computer and so for example we
might have a
graphical user interface where we're
like pressing things that are
graphically showing up on the screen
we might have a command line interface
where we're typing commands into the
computer
uh just you know type type type do
something telling the computer what to
do and so on
but these are interfaces between humans
and the computer
but it's often the case in kind of the
infrastructure of the world
in addition to humans communicating with
computers there are lots and lots of
computers
that need to communicate with computers
and so there might be a computer that um
oh for example is uh
uh doing um what would be a good example
oh i don't know it's a um
[Music]
uh
let's say a computer that is doing a
financial transaction
where it's told you know every week
somebody said transfer this money to
this account
okay so then there's a computer that has
a task that's running on it that says
that wakes up every week and says okay
now i'm going to transfer this money
okay what is it going to do well what it
has to do is it has to tell another
computer
to go do that money transfer the
question is how does it
communicate with that other computer you
know does it
use the graphical user interface of the
other computer does it use a command
line interface no it doesn't do either
of those things
it uses what's called an api an
application program interface
which is a way in which uh programs
expose an interface for computers to use
the program or for other programs to use
the program
and so what what what do apis look like
um it it depends uh a lot of different
details about how these work
the most common kind of api in modern
times the web api
and um uh in a um
so when you go to a website you type in
the url for the website
and the thing you get is you know you
might type in i don't know wolfram.com
and what you will get back is you you'll
type that into your web browser
and what the web the server the computer
that we have at you know wolfram.com
is sending back a big bunch of html
code that gets sent back to your browser
program
and your browser program then displays
it as a beautiful website
but uh and so that's that's using
that's a web address that you give in
the in the
uh you know url bar of the browser
okay there are also you can also have a
web
api it's also a url
but it's a url that instead of sending
back typically
html intended for human consumption it
might send back
all kinds of random data that is not
intended for human consumption
it's intended for consumption by a
program and so that would be
kind of an api where a web api
where you're using the web to
communicate the information
uh you're still using the http protocol
that appears at the beginning of the
the full form of the url you're still
using that protocol
you're still but but instead of it being
something where you're sending the data
back to a browser for
to be displayed by a human uh to be
displayed for a human
it might be instead of the instead of
you as a human typing that url in a
program
might be generating that url and then
sending
a message to the web server through http
and then the web server is sending back
this blob of information
that comes back not to a browser but to
another kind of program
so if you go to a web api in a browser
you can go there and instead of getting
back a
nice beautiful html you might get back
some blob of
for example json which is a
textually readable output you might get
back some
you know piece of symbolic wolfram
language code
you might get back a binary pile of gunk
that was intended for for community for
for communication to a particular kind
of program
but the point is you're getting back
something that wasn't really intended
for you as a human
it was intended for a program to to
receive it
so there are these um apis
that are things where oh and typically
the other thing to say about a web api
is when you go to a website many
websites are static websites
in the sense that the you you go to that
url
orphan.com for example and it's just
like everybody who goes to that url
gets the same results back gets the same
nice website coming back
okay in a web uh in a url
there can be a question mark in the url
and then there are various things that
you can give blah equals blah blah blah
and so on
after that question mark those are a
typical way to specify parameters
for uh that can be used in an api when
you're when you're treating that url
as something that's specifying that
that's that's
uh when you're using it uh to
communicate with an api
those parameters after the question mark
are the sort of the things you feed into
the api
now in world from language for example
it's extremely easy to create a web api
you basically just say to make a public
one you just say cloud publish
api function and you give a piece of
code in there
and what that will do is it will set up
a url
it will tell you the url it's setting up
that will be a url that that
is is uh exists on our servers on our
cloud server
um at least in the default way you do it
it exists on our cloud server and then
anybody who goes
to that cloud server with the
appropriate parameters
after the question mark in the url will
basically be running the piece of code
you specified in that api
function and then you'll get back the
results for that and you'll get those
back i mean
you might happen to set it up so the
results that come back
are html so they're displayable as a
sort of visual stuff in a browser
but more likely you'd set it up as
something which will be consumed by a
program
so that it isn't it isn't intended for
human uh
uh you know human reading it's intended
for program consumption
and that's that's the more common case
now now
you know in addition to web apis so so
often wrapped around a web api
might be some kind of programming
language that is
making the calls of the web api so for
example you could have a wolfram
language program
that uses a url read to read for url
execute actually would be better
to execute a web api that the
that url execute uh command in wolfram
language
would go and um uh and and um
uh and make that web request and get the
result back and
and and then make it uh use it within
the wolfram language program
do the same thing from any programming
language you know java python whatever
else
um they all have capabilities for for
calling web apis
so that's the most common sort of form
of api
but there are different protocols for
apis so you don't have to be
sort of a fake web browser to to use an
api there are other
types of apis that um don't necessarily
even go through the web at all
they're just apis that can exist
either between computers or on a single
computer you could have
a uh something on a single computer
where you're running a program
and it has a way that other programs can
communicate with it
and you would commonly say it has a
certain api and so
the the the way that's used in sort of
modern software engineering
uh it's like a program has all kinds of
things that are going on inside it
and it exposes certain apis it exposes
certain things
you can poke it in certain ways you can
say do an x
do a y do a z and then it will respond
and that that that sort of way of poking
it that x y or z or whatever
those are features of its api so to
speak
so sometimes people who are used to
software engineering will generalize
that a bit
and they'll say you know if you're
thinking about biology for example
and you're thinking about some type of
cell you know you could say well the
cell has certain things that exposes
on the cell surface it has certain a
certain sort of api to the rest of the
uh
of the human body or something that's
what it exposes and that all kinds of
things going on inside the cell
but it's exposing a certain sort of api
to the outside world
that's kind of a generalization a sort
of software engineering
uh metaphor for what happens in other
places
but in in a in a um in a computer
setting
it's you know the api is the program to
program interface
there's another um
well it's it's uh yeah so there are a
few other kinds of things there's
another
notion an ffi foreign function interface
um api is usually
well okay so so apis
usually have a comparatively simple
structure
they're like there's a particular
command there's a particular service
provided by the api
it's like do this here's the parameters
for that service and come back with the
results
when things get more complicated it
isn't really feasible
to encode things in the form of
you know a key of value a key of value
it gets more complicated that's where
computational language design that i
spend my time doing
really comes in when you want to specify
a more sophisticated kind of
uh way to define what you want to do you
have to give this sort of whole
language structure and and that requires
a sort of a more elaborate way to
communicate program to program
so for example we built a thing uh used
to be called math link it's now called
wstp
or from symbolic transfer protocol we
actually built this in 1989. a really
really long time ago it's a way of
communicating
sort of arbitrary computational actions
between programs so instead of just
saying
oh uh you know here's this one parameter
that i want to give to specify what this
other program should do
you can say here is this symbolic
representation of a computational action
that can be generated by one program
sent to another program
then the other program can execute that
computational action
and give the result back and so that's a
a more sophisticated kind of api
that would instead of using http um to
where you're just sending these
sort of strings of bytes in in encoded
uh for for a web system uh it's you're
using wstp
colon and that is a then you're using
this this different kind of protocol
that allows you to send these arbitrary
symbolic expressions
representing kind of arbitrary
computational actions
so that's a that's a rough introduction
to apis
and uh you know in in the in the world
of the future where
where there are lots of ais running
around you know do the artificial
intelligences
kind of turn that turn their
communications
into something that's kind of human
level understandable or do they all have
apis where they're communicating
in a form that's sort of computed a
computer and understanding the world of
computers
but not necessarily understandable to us
that's sort of a challenge for the
future
well let's see
um
there's a question here
um
[Music]
okay there's a question from colin about
if the average human brain was
represented as a pc what would its
technical specifications be its core
count its clock speed
its ram its storage space etc
interesting question well we know a
certain amount about the brain the brain
seems to have about 100 billion neurons
the human brain has about 100 billion
neurons
and it has about maybe a hundred
trillion total connections between those
neurons
and each connection uh each synapse that
is a connection between neurons
is perhaps stores
i don't know maybe a thousand bits of
information
maybe roughly so
uh and and the neurons in our brains are
all sort of operating in parallel
they're all you know neurons on one side
of the brain are firing at the same time
as another side of the brain and so on
and but they do it comparatively slowly
on a time scale of a milliseconds
thousandth of a second
um on the other hand when we think about
a particular thing
there's some evidence that that sort of
the thoughts are somehow localized so
we're not really using
all of the neurons firing in other parts
of the brain we might be using them for
our vision system
you know the primary visual cortex to
the back of one's head is um
is sort of you know all those neurons
are firing and processing you know the
pixel from this position
etc etc etc but uh when we're sort of
thinking a concentrated thought
it's not clear how broadly that spreads
in the brain and to what extent it's
localized
um but uh but but so let's assume that
let's just for the sake of argument
assume that the whole brain
is sort of active all the time let's say
it has a cycle time of millisecond
which is very slow compared to a
computer i mean a modern computer
will typically have uh the the clock
frequency of a modern computer might be
two gigahertz or five gigahertz
so that's five five billion cycles per
second
as opposed to on the order of a thousand
cycles per second
so we're kind of we're kind of losing so
it'll be a one kilohertz computer
that we have but it would be one
kilohertz computer then effect
has uh something more like you know 100
billion cores
all operating at that fairly low speed
but each core
has let's say assuming it's connected
um to uh let's see um
a thousand okay so let's say each core
would have maybe a hundred thousand bits
associated with it of of memory which is
tiny i mean that's that's some
you know that's 10 kilobytes of memory
basically um
so so in those in those terms what we
will be saying is
uh let's see it's um 10 kilobytes 25
bytes
um times uh
well let's say it's a that's 10 to the
17
um uh so that would be um
um so that's a
that's that's almost a million trillion
bits or almost a million
uh so let's say uh
let's knock it down a bit so i think
that will be about um
uh uh 10 000 terabytes
or 10 petabytes of um of information
will be roughly the storage capacity
with assuming that
that things are stored that way now the
way that we store things in the brain we
have no idea
the details of how that storage works
and how redundant it is
how many bits we use you know in a
computer we might just have a
you know when we store a number in a
computer it might just be there's one
copy of the number
but in our brains there might
effectively be lots of different
versions of that number scattered all
over the place but
but in round numbers maybe 10 petabytes
of um
of information might be a guess and then
we can ask the question
um but we're processing that at
um the the aggregate processing speed
if we sort of combine all our cores
together if they were all working in
parallel
might be on the order of let's see
that's um
uh 10 gigahertz times um
so that would be on the order of a
terahertz
if everything was sort of working in
parallel which it undoubtedly isn't so
it's undoubtedly much slower than that
and then so we can ask questions like
um as we experience the world um
how much data are we ingesting how much
data do we you know how much how much do
we see in our lifetime
you know we might have um you know as as
we look around
we might see a different scene in our
eyes moving these sick ads
but if we ignore that and we just say
how many different scenes let's say we
see
a different scene let's just say we see
a different scene every
a few times a minute okay and um
uh let's say we see a different scene
every 10 seconds
okay so in our first so every year uh
assuming so we're let's there are 30
million seconds in a year
and so let's knock it down a bit for you
know being asleep
and this and that and the other so let's
say it's 20 million seconds that are
relevant and let's say
every 10 seconds we see something
different so that's
2 million different things we see per
year and
our eyes are roughly like 10 megapixel
cameras
um so they our eyes uh see about
uh 10 million pixels in one kind of one
one uh and they see it um the the
the well our eyes have a persistence
time of order 1 15th of a second so
every
10 times a second roughly we can sort of
see a different image on our eyes but
that's not in practice what we're saying
we're saying
like every 10 seconds or something we
might see something different so we're
saying
2 million of those per year and our eyes
are ingesting let's say if we
looked at every single pixel it might be
10 megapixels so that's some
uh um 20 times um
20 trillion um
that would be uh 20 roughly
let's say uh 20 trillion 20 terror
let's say you know on a few terabytes
per year of um uh you know the movie
that we see per year
might you know of really different
scenes
might be of order 20 terabytes or some
number of terabytes
the movie the the sort of maximum speed
movie where every frame is different
might be more in the petabyte range but
so so what we're seeing is that the the
total
information that we can see from our
eyes is
is of the order of of um uh you know in
a
in a lifetime might be getting up to the
um
uh the the tens to hundreds of terabytes
so we kind of
still have we you know if we're
efficient in storing that
we'd kind of have enough storage in our
brains to store all of that
the fact is we certainly don't recognize
we certainly don't notice
every single pixel and every scene we're
seeing we probably extract
a very small amount of sort of summary
information from every scene we see so
it's a lot easier to fit that
information
into a brain so so that uh you know we
we can we can store those kinds of
images if we think about
you know how many words have we heard um
you know we might um
uh we might let's see if we um uh well
let's let's work it out if we if we
um uh i think it's silent reading is
like
200 words per minute so that means if we
are
uh if we're like reading reading reading
all the time um
let's say we read um uh let's see 200
words per minute
is um uh every second we're
we're reading um on the order of uh well
let's say three words per second
um so that means um uh
we are um uh
let's see so that would mean if we were
reading for 10 million seconds a
a year which means we're reading one
third of the time so 10 million seconds
a year
times um um three words per second would
be
would be 30 million words per per year
um that we will be reading instead of
silent reading and how big is 30 million
words per year that's some
let's see uh um a uh
a typical book well let's work out that
out i mean a typical book
might have i don't know maybe 40
characters per line maybe
um maybe a little less than that depends
on the width of the book
uh maybe 30 characters per line and
maybe
50 characters per page 50 lines per page
so that would be um uh am i getting this
right a hundred and
um 1500 characters per page
so that means times let's say um uh
1500 characters per page um
would be um uh boy i was never very good
at mental arithmetic so
hopefully many people out there can do
this much faster than i can
um so that's um 1.5 times 10 to the 3
times let's say um 1.5 times 10 to 5.
um so that's um 150 000
characters per book let's say so let's
say let's say a hundred thousand
characters per book
um and so this uh the thing we just
estimated
of reading 10 million uh characters or
maybe we said 30 million characters per
year um would be uh let's say it's 10
million characters per year that's 10 to
the seven
divided by uh that's not very many
that's uh that's surprisingly few that
would be um
well with that estimate we'd be saying
you would read um
at that speed you would read a hundred
books per year which seems which seems
low i think we're
probably if we put in a few more of
those factors we're probably a little
bit more accurate it's more like a few
hundred books per year
um so it gives you gives you a little
bit of a sense of scale there
um well
so that that's some uh rough estimates
but brains
brains probably we already know from the
operation of artificial neural nets
that brains probably work in rather
different ways from the ways that we're
used to having computers work
all right maybe one more question
here um
let's see
question from mikael why is it difficult
for our brains to perform many simple
calculations in a row
hmm interesting question i mean i think
that uh
doing things like math and logic and so
on these sort of abstract fields are not
very natural for brains
they're also not very natural for
artificial neural networks
i mean i think one of the challenges i
mean some people are much better than
others
like i was just exercising my mental
arithmetic abilities
um such as they are and i think um uh
it's um uh you know you you
doing simple
operations that are defined in a simple
symbolic way
in terms of numbers or logic or whatever
just not a very good match for brains
brains can take a picture and say well
they're roughly these features and those
features and this is roughly how we'll
represent that picture
um but that's a very different thing
from saying it's precisely the number
seven
it's precisely this logic you know true
or false logic thing
and brains just aren't very good at that
and probably we store those things
by kind of saying oh it's kind of like a
a picture where it's all blue versus all
red
and that's a totally inefficient way to
think about storing these things which
for purposes of our sort of abstract
computation
or our actual digital computers are
really efficient and easy to deal with
okay well
i think we should probably um uh
wrap up for now here if there's
something else i can do
quickly oh there's a reasonably quick
one here
from parmenides is the eightfold way of
marigold man easier or more difficult
than learning quantum criminal dynamics
it's kind of easier
i mean it was named the eightfold way
after after the buddha thing
but it has nothing to do with the buddha
it has to do with
um uh just a uh the the
it's it's the fact that particles like
protons pions neutrons
whatever are made of quarks and um
the the eightfold way murray's kind of
cutesy eightfold way idea
is it turns out there if you have three
kinds of quarks
up down and strange for example and you
combine those three together
in three different uh in you you have
particles that are made from three
quarks at a time
so you might have an up up up particle
you might have an up up down
up down strange up strange strange et
cetera et cetera et cetera
it turns out for the the sort of the
the most common kinds of particles there
are exactly eight ways to make those
combinations
and they correspond to eight common
kinds of particles uh
well uh protons and neutrons the sigma
hyperons the lambda hyperon and the
psi cascade hyperons these are the
different kinds of baryons
they were all discovered in the 1950s
and
that are made of three quarks
and it so happens that the mesons
that are things like the pion which is
responsible for holding nuclei together
um it so happens those are made of quark
antiquark pairs
it so happens that because of the
details of the um
uh of the way that combinations of of
of objects work um that you have um that
they're the same number
that the the three pions the k ons
uh the um uh
oh yeah the anti chaons yeah they're
also in the same multiplex
and the and the eta particle are all um
uh uh all from uh there are eight of
those and they come from the quark
antiquark
uh uh combination so so it's kind of a
but but in the more fancy mathematics
um and the way this was originally
discovered was by using group theory
theory of continuous groups so-called
lead groups kind of the
the the analog of calculus for group
theory
and those are parts of the irreducible
representations the irreducible
representations
of the group su-3 and that's the story
of
how one understands but you can
understand the eight-fold way just in
terms of counting quarks
you don't have to go fancy group theory
and you don't have to start talking
about
matrices representing uh corresponding
to the representations of groups and so
on
qcd the theory of quarks and gluons is a
more elaborate theory where the
where now the the su-3 symmetry
is a symmetry of color uh notionally
color it's not really color
it's a it's a an internal feature of
quarks and gluons
that's a different thing from the are
you and up corker down quark a strange
quark that's so-called flavor
uh symmetry uh color symmetry is a sort
of internal parameter
of quarks and gluons and the way that
that um
uh that that theory is considerably more
elaborate um and involves sort of a
a good mathematical theory understanding
of that theory involves thinking about
fiber bundles
and connections on fiber bundles and all
kinds of more more elaborate sorts of
things
so i should wrap up there um
i think we're going to um uh uh probably
uh think about some potential themes for
these um
uh uh these live streams as i say we're
doing business and innovation and
history
and of science and technology and
alternating weeks
on a different day i think for uh this
live stream which i
really had hoped to be at least at a
level
that was accessible to uh uh
to kids and so on um we might uh we
might try and start picking some
some specific themes that people have
suggestions please uh
feel free to send them in um and
see where we go with that all right well
thanks for joining us
and see you another time